le gouvernement a annoncé qu'il allait
droit d'être vendues en pharmacie à
partir du 12
je suis pas dire qu'ils seront présentes
en acier partir du 12 on a eu
l'autorisation hier matin un dimanche
les précommandes c'est depuis trois
semaines au moins donc là les
fournisseurs sont dans les starting
blocks je vais les recevoir dans la
semaine des autotests de la cause 19 qui
se font attendre dans les officines en
ce premier jour d'autorisation de vente
les clients vont donc devoir patienter
on va pouvoir leur dire prochainement ce
qu'on n'a pas encore les tests on peut
pas s'avancer maintenant d'aller prix on
a acquis on peut les donner donc c'est
déjà une bonne chose qu'on puisse
répondre quelque chose aux patients dès
réception de leur commande les
pharmacies vendrons ces auto test une
trentaine d'euros par lot de 5 pour le
propriétaire de la pharmacie de l'espace
saint quentin pas sûr que ses clients
adhèrent les gens pas l'air de vouloir
se précipiter pour acheter les autotests
sachant que les tests antigénique la 6e
sont gratuits enfin si on va tuer pas
payer de leur poche
donc tu préfère faire les tests
antigénique classique plutôt d'acheter
les autotests qui sont vendus par cinq
aux alentours de 30 euros la boîte donc
les bons payant pour le grand public
mais la sécurité sociale pourra prendre
en charge ce coup notamment pour les
personnes travaillant avec des personnes
âgées ou handicapées s'est auto test
devrait donc arriver dans le courant de
la semaine dans les pharmacies
yvelinoise